[Music]
we think that being authentic is about
remaining true to who we are and many of
us consider plastic surgery to be more
the preserve of celebrities your Caitlyn
Jenner you're a Chelsea Manning rather
than ordinary people but in fact plastic
surgery has become seen as a way of
trying to enhance or authenticate our
inner lives
so should we embrace cosmetic
transformation as a way of becoming
closer to who we really are or who we
might want or aspire to become or should
we go in the other way and saying that
society is far too obsessed with
appearance and that we need to push back
against that well to debate argue and we
hope possibly even resolved at least for
a little bit some of these questions we
have three fantastic speakers for you
here today on my left we have Heather
Peter who is lgbtq+ labour trail as in
Labour Party's transgender officer and
also holds a PhD in biochemistry from
Cambridge so we expect both ideology and
science to be with us today Heather on
the right hand side as as I'm looking we
have Julie along who is a researcher
into violence against women and the
author of anti-porn the resurgence of
anti-pornography feminism and she also
holds a PhD in social science and miles
Barry on my immediate right here is a
plastic surgeon he is in private
practice he has immense amounts of
experience in this area so three highly
qualified people to debate this issue
today and before we start with the
debate itself we're going to hear from
each of our speakers and get a three
minutes from them about what their
position is on this debate about the
connection between authenticity and
plastic surgery
Heather Peter could I start with you yes
thank you Anna
and I suppose an invitation to myself in
a dr. Julia long and the subjects of
capital in gender Jenna means that one
of the parts of this question is if
you're trans and does transitioning and
does surgery help you to transition and
whether you need to change you
appearance to seek to society demands
and I'd just say you a few little bits
about them being transgender before I
get on to the issue in the debate I mean
like sexuality gender identity for most
of us is something that we've known our
gender identity our conflicts with our
body are from a very early age and it's
really tough growing up if your body and
your mind is different and you exposed
to all the role models and gender
stereotypes of your gender identity but
you'll then punished if you express
yourself in that way and and society
does portray men and women differently
and what in terms of clothing and makeup
an image is regarded as sexy or
beautiful and trans women are exposed to
these stereotypes just like other girls
are so just like most women we feel
inadequate when held up to images on the
cover folk but wearing beautiful worm
clothes and makeups does make us feel
better more confident about ourselves
and empowered and there is an additional
thing if you're trans which is your body
your genitalia for example doesn't match
what your head says it should be and in
a short talk I can't explain or give
justice to explaining the pain that
gender dysphoria has but in this debate
we are talking about what medical
interventions you can do to change your
body and whether that makes yourself
more authentic so there's three main
ways that transgender people become more
true to themselves and a fourth which is
the full cosmetic surgery which i think
is really only available to the very
rich the first is social transition I
won't go into that too much because it's
not really part of this debate but the
second is hormone treatment and I would
say that that is far more radical than
most plastic surgery and it's far more
empowering I mean your body over the
space of a few months does become more
of what you want it to be your whole
body changes your secondary
characteristics changes and your mind
changes as well and with a positive
psychological win
impact so answering the question that is
this date I'd say yes hormone plastic
surgery to give it that word does make
your body closer to who you are and so
more authentic for some gender
reassignment surgery is the way to go to
change your genitalia to be more I am
you know reflective of what is inside
your head to be I won't be too crude but
you know sex is only a short part of
your life but it is a very important
part and having your genitalia matching
what your mind is is really important as
well as not waking up and going into the
shower each morning and being reminded
that you're somehow different so yes I'd
say having sexual reassignment surgery
is also important when it comes to
plastic surgery though I think that's
more complicated and I think it depends
you know I I was reflecting myself I do
wear makeup and it does make me feel
more confident but why why do I wear
makeup
should I be pushed into this idea of
sort like there's an ideal image to
present and if so sort like should I
take something out if I had the money as
radical as plastic surgery I'd say for
myself no I wouldn't criticize anyone
else for doing so thank you very much
indeed
Heather and we'll turn straight to Julia
Julia on your three-minute picture
please thank you so the question that we
were given was can plastic and plastic
surgery makers more authentic people I
think we need to be quite clear that
what we're talking about on this panel
is cosmetic surgery so we're not talking
about plastic surgery in the sense of
surgery that is done well where an
individual has experienced severe burns
or injury or disease we're not talking
about that we're talking about cosmetic
surgery which is done to otherwise
healthy individuals um healthy tissue so
we're talking about a range of surgical
practices and I think it's also
important to talk about other invasive
procedures which may not be a surgical
but of becoming very normalized and very
popularized through a lot of media
narratives so this word offend
we really have seen a lot of in the last
couple of years I would say particularly
particularly in this area of so-called
gender identity in the notion of having
an authentic self I find it I find it
quite troubling that there seems to be a
way from what we understand as
sociologists as the self that obviously
we will all have a some of the kind of
sense of ourselves that is in
relationship to the social world to the
political world the economic world that
we inhabit so this idea of authenticity
is often I think use very ideologically
in these kinds of discussions or in
terms of the claims of young people
invested in cosmetic surgery to suggest
that there's some kind of inner self
that is pre-social
that is not affected by the kind of
messages that we have from the media
remember that obviously the media is
extremely powerful and it's in the hands
of you know very few very powerful
corporations and all of the economic
interests that are that are at stake in
terms of a hugely profitable cosmetic
surgery industry that we know it can be
quite hard to find accurate estimates of
the of the global worth of you know
different industries I've seen estimates
ranging from 11 billion right up to 43
billion US dollars in but what we do
know is that cosmetic surgery is a
hugely booming business both in terms of
the surgical procedures and the very
common increasingly prevalent invasive
procedures so I want to start by raising
a question there's a a woman whose story
I was reading recently I won't say her
name out of respect but I'll just call
her Jane Smith Jane Smith was a survivor
of the p IP breast implant scandal that
some of you will probably remember from
the best part of 10 years ago now 2012
is when that scandal broke if you
remember with the PAP scandal women had
breast implants put into their bodies
that had industrial grade silicone and
were far wood
is likely to rupture than other implants
so there were 48 thousand women in this
country alone that were victims of this
scandal they waited five years for any
kind of financial compensation they got
three thousand pounds which would not
even cover the cost of the original the
original operation and Jane Smith as
just one example of these women has had
to have five further operations to try
and correct some of the the impact of
having this toxic substance leaked into
her body so we can raise the question
we've got all these sort of ideological
words like authentic or confidence or
you know boosting self-esteem because I
would like to raise the question is Jane
Smith a more authentic person now with
this toxic material in her body that can
never be fully got rid of that as that
has affected her ability to work her
ability to raise children her ability to
function in the world not to mention all
the psychological impacts as well as the
physical impacts and I think we really
have to look at get away from some of
the euphemistic language that tends to
be used in these discussions and start
to think about whose interest is this
serving who's making huge profits out of
this what are their implications in
terms of sexual politics because we know
that it is overwhelmingly men who are
carrying out these procedures and women
90 in this country 90% of all cosmetic
surgery is carried out on women's bodies
and what abates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at AI
TV
you